Hallo Amy, danke, dass du dich uns angeschlossen hast. Du warst
schon einmal in einem Online-Topsail und ich
nehme an, aber ich habe kein sehr gutes
Gedächtnis, aber ich gebe viele Interviews. Ich bin
sicher, dass es schon einmal eines gegeben hat
wirklich gut ja und war dort im
urlaub weil ich geburtstag hatte also bin ich
heute wieder was und dann
läuft alles gut ja also heißt es kill to be
back in germany okay glückwunsch zu
deinem geburtstag du bist sehr sehr beliebt
in deutschland es ist  anders als in anderen
Ländern in Europa und ich glaube, ich hatte
mehr Erfolg in Deutschland, aber ich hatte
großes Glück, dass ich Erfolg hatte und auch an
anderen Orten war, in Österreich, Frankreich, der
Schweiz, Spanien und Großbritannien, also bin ich sehr,
sehr glücklich  In dieser Position zu sein und
ich bin einfach sehr dankbar für die Unterstützung.
Sie sind immer noch überrascht. Erfolg ja,
immer und es ist immer etwas,
wovon ich geträumt habe und das ich immer tun wollte, aber in dieser Branche ist es sehr
unbeständig und man weiß nie  wie
es so kommen wird  Ich bin immer überrascht,
aber sehr, sehr glücklich und aufgeregt, dass es
heißt, wenn Sie wirklich das haben, als
Sie ein kleines Mädchen waren, haben Sie eine Idee,
die passieren könnte, und nicht wirklich, weil Sie in
dieser Branche, wie ich sagte, nie wissen,
wie es ausgehen wird  Also habe ich geträumt, dass
ich das eines Tages tun könnte, aber ich
wusste nie, dass es tatsächlich passiert
ist, also kam alles wie ein Schock für mich
super gleich ja, du machst
jetzt eine sehr tolle Tour durch Deutschland zu
all den großen Arenen, die wir haben, das ist auch
ein Schock für euch Investoren, sehr aufregend,
es ist nicht so sehr ein Schock, weil
ich mich hochgearbeitet habe, um diese Gags
zuletzt zu machen  Kuchen werden in Deutschland gespielt, wir haben
sehr große Löcher, also war der nächste Schritt nur
zu diesen Orten, aber es ist sehr aufregend
und er.
Ich freue mich auch sehr darauf.
Ich hoffe, Sie werden viel
Spaß haben  Diese große
Menschenmenge ist einfach unglaublich
aufregend, meine ich  Es gibt so viele Menschen
auf der Welt, die nur davon träumen,
und ich bin in der Lage, es zu tun, also bin ich sehr
dankbar dafür und freue mich wirklich darauf
, rauszukommen und dann
alle Songs vor meinen Fans zu spielen mm-hmm und was
Glaubst du, wo das alles hinführt,
deine Karriere? Ich weiß nicht, wie ich schon sagte,
bevor die Sonne dich verteilt. Du weißt nicht,
wie die Dinge an der Spitze laufen, und dann
könnte am nächsten Tag alles
um dich herum zusammenbrechen  Ich weiß also nicht,
was in den nächsten Jahren passieren wird,
aber wenn ich das weiter machen
würde, wäre ich glücklich, weil
es mir Spaß macht und mich glücklich macht. Was
sagen Ihre Freunde dazu und
sie sind es  nur ziemlich nah wie meine Familie,
sie waren von
Anfang an dabei und haben wirklich gebetet,
dass es so gut für mich gelaufen ist, und
sie sind alle sehr, sehr unterstützend, wie
viel Zeit haben Sie für sie
und ich sorge dafür  nehme mir Zeit und meine
Familie und Freunde sind der
wichtigste Teil meines Lebens, also
stelle ich immer sicher, dass ich  Ich habe ein Team zu Hause und
bin gekommen, um alle in meiner Nähe zu sehen, aber wenn du
es schaffst, ist es möglich, na ja, du
gehst immer nach Hause, wenn ein Tutor nicht
ewig hält, in diesem Fall ist es vielleicht ein
Monat oder so, Lenny, aber sie wissen es
Team hab ich nachher zu hause würde
es klappen und ich habe mich
mittlerweile total daran gewöhnt ja und wenn du zu hause
bist meine ich du bist anfangs nicht
einige wochen erschöpft ja die ganze zeit
wenn ich fast bei bin  Es waren die guten paar
Tage
, an denen ich mich nur verbeugte und fernsah, dass ich nicht wirklich viel aufstehe,
weil es einfach schön ist,
wieder seinen eigenen Raum zu haben und sich entspannen zu können
, okay,
also wünschen wir dir viel Glück dabei
tolle tour danke und viel erfolg für die
nächsten jahrzehnte danke
vielen dank danke dir